I just found Jenna at the entrance to the Microsoft press conference. We're here this is E3, technically
I mean it’s not even day one, so basically it’s day zero. Are excited Jenna?  Yes, are you ready ? We’ve got a couple things of stairs to do.
Oh, okay, but it's premium seats.
Made it into the press conference and look who I found.
Okay, going to have [nice] curative. What's up okay? [hi], [Darla].  Do I look Green? Green like everyone else. I'm the greens. This is actually my natural kid
I wouldn't expect anything more from you
DRAMATIC MUSIC
and today we are
[the] newest [members] [of] the Xbox family fittingly named
XBOX ONE X
The most powerful console ever made [sets] a new quality standard for gamers [new] [game] creators
starting on November 7th
Xbox One X join's the Xbox One and the Xbox One S, when it launches worldwide
We just got out of the Xbox E3 presentation, where I keep wanting to call it Xbox Scorpios
So do I, but it’s not . Introduce yourself to my wonderful internet friends here, I’m Albert Penello , I run console marketing at Microsoft
This is the Xbox One X
There were so many DMX jokes people were making, were they. Yeah, like it was great.
I love DMX by the way , so just want to put that out there.
True story , I’ve had the old no power greater than X logo on my twitter
logo on my twitter feed for like a year
And I've just been waiting for this moment. That’s hilarious .
Yeah, been there the whole time and here it is so you guys went through so many different things today, what are the high level things
That everyone wants to know of course the specs.
Hey, I want to say it starts with the games we had a great games lineup
We showed 42 games on our stage the most diverse lineup 22 console exclusives
We should amazing true 4k games like Forth. Assassin's creed. It was an unbelievable lineup of games
This is the this is my baby
This is the machine that powers at all. It is the world's most powerful console [6] teraflops 12 gigabytes of GDDR5 memory
326 gigabytes per Second Memory, Bandwidth
It is the small I will use my aladdin [Jo] unlimited Cosmic power itty-Bitty living space
We have crammed a lot of performance into the small sex
We've ever built yeah, so it looks [compatible], and then we show them the bathroom
We came to do you didn't mention much about the city? Yeah, we didn't get to talk [about] it [in] [fact]
You know it shares that beautiful family resemblance with the Xbox one ass, but in the side, it's completely different the only component inside
That's shared with an Xbox one s is the Blu-Ray drive
But one of the things that we wanted to do when I just talked [about] the care and craftsmanship that we put in
Was on the port arrangement, and I know it sounds silly
But it's [the] level of detail that we have with the team is that all the ports are in the same place on Xbox [one]?
Is we even use the same power cable?
Which is a huge fight between the marketing team and the engineering team to make that happen?
But it means that if you're upgrading from an Xbox one ass, I don't have to look I don't have to get behind the TV
Exactly, they're all [saying] ports you can do if I feel that's actually use right now because I'll tell you how many times I mean
I'm sure I'm not the only one everyone's drunk like okay is it and I have like what I will do is
I'll [use] the [front-facing] camera on my phone and I start in behind my TV
I'm just like okay great. Got it
It's going to be the weirdest feeling [cuz] it really if you literally just go like that
And it just works so you can afraid really [fiddle] [now]. I'm deaf people compared to the Xbox one edge
I wish we had what to show you that it is a little bit smaller
It's two pounds heavier. [then] Xbox [one] [as] to when you pick this thing up. You're like
Oh my God
it is and
there is so much tech that we crammed in [here] and to do it with this level [of] performance to
[keep] the elegant design to keep it cool [and] quiet. I think you've heard us talk [about] things like the vapor chamber
Which you normally see on the servers and high-end PC graphics cards?
There's actually a guy back at work
bill hobus who had to invent a power management system [that] basically looks at every chip in the console and
the Motherboard in total and optimizes each
Xbox 1x individually so that it's the most efficient it can be so we don't waste any power, and it allows it. Thanks bill
People's electric bills will be a little bit smaller. Thanks to bill hovis and it keeps all [that] performance in
In the smallest console we've ever built and another thing as you guys mention
Which is so exciting [for] people who have been Xbox fans in the beginning?
We can now play old-school Xbox original [games], so there are unreal look I gotta say. I was sitting there in the crowd
I've been wanting to share this people for so long
[there] are guys on the team like myself that have been around since we launched the original
Console that wanted to see this happen. Phil's wanted to see it happen your discs work you can you take your discs they work?
if you
Basically your digital entitlement to work. Just like back and pat and
You can actually system link all three generations of consoles together for land parties, so you can get an oG xbox?
360 and an Xbox one
That's right
You can actually do land parties with your old discs on three generations of consoles they know this but I?
Skipped out on one of my proms to go to a lan party all right
But it was a PC lan party at the time so yeah [is] back into that public awareness. Good night
Yes, what a fight made five [dates]
I think you guys did an [incredible] job at the [press] [conference] in stage looked unbelievable?
[we] were here in person and those screens or unreal I
Apologize at home if you did not get to see the magnificence of the 4:3 screen. We have there
November
$799 nothing in the world this level of performance at that price and
Get one quick like [mario] yeah. Thank you so much. This is off of [it] now. It's [do] the little slow-mo montage
this is the new Xbox one x
Let me know comment below and let me know what you guys think what are you most looking forward to and what?
Old-school Xbox game are you most looking forward to play backwards compatibility for the way? I'll see you guys later
getting a mug images